taste buds they com to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like b a t t l e bus Wow
first first guest to know the chant and
do it with us listen if I'm going to law
school am I going to watch suits first
probably look at that that's if I got
that slice in a restaurant in a Pizer
I'd be like can I you're a restaurant
got a h pocket in a restaurant get him
boys I would burn it I would say I would
say guys where's the cheese there's no
cheese on this if they served me a Hot
Pocket as a calzone I'd punch him in the
mouth that's true
that's you're saying what you're what
you're saying argument there was nothing
worse than the erasable pen when I was a
kid we can both agree on that yeah when
I was a kid I thought it was the coolest
thing and what you learn is it's [__]
ink yeah doesn't stick to the
page taste bir